hi welcome to Peru these are the coffee
cherries I love coffee to make a video
about fair trade coffee
my name is Lenny I drink coffee for a
living you've been drinking your coffee
wrong and I will tell you why this is
the process of capping coffee but is
capping capping is the process of
identification or the flavor of the
coffee we can identify if the coffee
will be good or bad we are going to
signature province until we sit my
mother's fire we are in common all the
place I was born my history of coffee
starts here in this small town I feel so
proud of my mom because she was her
mother she was coffee farmers my brother
they broke apart and I think it was hard
for her to take care for two children
always she was thinking about okay I
want my songs to be a professional I am
the first member of the family that went
to study to the University I study
international business minima is a
median Olivia talked on the national
cooperative isola cafe hot after I
studied at university I started working
in that cooperative tapping coffee is
really hard to become a key grader
because many exams 21 exams you have to
train your nose your tongues and try to
smell everything we are in Sala cafe
these farmers are bringing a coffee from
the Highland to resolve we are working
in two provinces in hiring and signaling
in the north of the room we have many
farmers
men and women and bringing the coffee to
the co-operative the farmers bring the
coffee to be great and taste it for
quality
this is a process of sorting the
Caulfield where we can identify the good
things for the bad ones via Menino San
Joaquin today what a pal we are going to
pick coffee just red cherries if you
want to produce a good coffee just to
pick the red beings muchas affirmative
this is akia after the picking the
coffee's ready to remove the pulp when
you remove a pool we get to beans we
ferment ate that coffee cherries for 24
or 48 hours is the paint the altitude of
the firm and then the coffee's ready for
washing then after that we dry the
coffee for almost 5 or 7 days it depends
the weather and then the coffee is ready
to be sold to the competitive Sala cafe
globally
the market value for coffee is well
below what we would consider to be a
living wage for coffee producers
worldwide it is definitely on all of the
consumers of coffee to start to question
how much companies are paying farmers
for their coffee being part of portray
see you we are protected about the
prices because we have a minimum price
this is different when you are a
conventional farmer because you are
worried about New York fair trade USA is
a nonprofit organization fair trade
started as a movement led by farmers
specifically and coffee cooperative
Italian polymer in Bend area York a
famous Capriccio special meant a yo
gracias a diós a usme cafe ok proceed oh
you gotta Mina mustn´t Alma yo IDO can
se hos copy is important because we can
know the value of the coffee and give
the best prices to the farmers we are
going to give an score they make sure
about the quality now
going to roast these green coffee to get
a roasted coffee we are going to put
into a roasting machine I need to make
sure about the color of the wings it
must be in the right color to be covered
you can see this is a uniform color and
now the coffee is ready here we have
five cups the five cups are from one
farmer we need to make sure that all
that cups are the same flavor in the
same sweetness the first step is try to
identify the fragrance of the coffee and
we are going to do like this we can find
flavors like chocolate blueberries
vanilla or like floral flavors with
sample this coffee to me is chocolate
and the second step is to put water into
the glasses the next step is break the
cup break the cup means do like this she
is identifying like floral flavors and
chocolate is very common in the Peruvian
coffee here at Sala cafe we have my
coffee profiles bang of Deng is boom
coffee the profile of this coffee is
dark chocolate is like blueberries very
complex I like this kind of coffee
parker's coffee this is a fruity coffee
with more hours or fermentation tres
Rios this coffee profile is just clean
cup a ma who is like a soft chocolate
with flavors like apples or mandarins
yesterday is our highest profile this
stuff is very floral after we break the
cup we we need to clean the cup then we
are going to do like this first clean
the spoons and then clean the cup after
the coffee is cooled down the coffee is
ready for capping and we are going to do
like this
[Music]
in this process we are going to defy the
flavor of the coffee the body of the
coffee the acidity of the coffee and the
aftertaste of the coffee I want to tell
you that behind the cup of coffee you
are drinking there is a hard work of
simple families humble families the
right way to drink coffee is the coffee
that supports coffee families make sure
about the Fairtrade zeal Directorate and
the fair trade are not mutually
exclusive and they actually benefit each
other when Coffee Roasters use both
you